You know,
from a strictly scientific perspective,
we think of human beings has nothing
but the children of nature and culture.
And that pushes you towards
a kind of deterministic view.
What causes your behavior?
Well,
it's either nature or culture
because there isn't anything else.
But that isn't how the mythological story
lays itself out because it says there
is something else and that's
whatever your consciousness is.
And that consciousness seems to be able
to work with nature and culture in a non
deterministic manner in order
to bring well in order for what?
In order to bring itself forward.
I mean,
and that's really what's interesting
about that I think is that it isn't
obviously just the plot of Pinocchio,
it's virtually the plot of any story
is the story of the development of the
individual.
Now the story is order chaos,
higher order,
roughly speaking.
So you can get variants of that.
You can get order collapses into
disorder and nothing is resolved.
That's a tragedy,
right?
And,
and you can get so,
so you don't have to have the entire
story represented in his story,
but you get fragments of it.
It's a classic.
You shaped story and what it is is
the story of the development of the
individual across time as a consequence
of his or her adventures in time and
space.
And every story is exactly that.
And those are representations
of the manner in which you
come to be in the world
for better or for worse.
It's differentiated.
So the individual has
a negative and a pause.
Development and culture
has a negative and a pause.
Development and nature does as well,
and that makes the potential
for plots much broader.
But I think it's also very useful to know
that entire story because I think it's
one of the things that
protects you against ideology.
It's like,
okay.
Whereas if someone tells you a
political story or a story of any sort,
you can always ask,
well,
where are the missing characters?
Human beings are terrible.
They've erected a culture
that's destroying the planet
and nature is beneath,
you know,
benevolent and and pristine.
It's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
Accurate.
But you're missing half the characters
because humans are not just terrible
rapacious creatures.
And culture is not just a
destructive force in nature,
is by no means on our side.
So where's the missing characters?
You need all of the characters in
the representation to get it right.
And I really believe this to be true.
So for example,
if you want to protect yourself against
trauma as you move forward in life,
you have to be very aware of the three,
three negative characters.
You have to know that the human individual
has an adversarial element that's
malevolent right to the core.
And if you don't know that and you
run across someone who's malevolent,
you will end up damaged.
So because first you won't
be able to defend yourself.
You'll just be like a ripe fruit
tree for the plucking and second,
the mere existence of someone like that
will pose such a to the way that you've
organized the world,
that it might collapse on you.
That happens to people all the time.
So it really matters whether you know
these categories and it matters that you
know that culture can become tyrannical.
It really,
but that it's also you're the
father that's given you everything.
And it matters that you know,
everything good comes from nature and
that we need to live in harmony with
nature to some degree.
But that it's also a hell bent
on our destruction every second.
And it's very paradoxical.
It's a,
it's a hard thing to reconcile with,
with,
with uh,
without a thought structure like modern
science that's based on a strict logic
that always says something can't be
itself and its opposite at the same time.
But you know,
human beings can certainly be something
and its opposite at the same time and
anything truly complex can have
that and does have that nature.
If someone offers you a new job,
you think,
well that's positive.
It's like no it's not.
It's positive and negative and complex.
It might be the solution to your problem
but at the same set time it's going to
generate a whole host of other problems.
So lots of times we're,
we're,
we're encountering entities in some
sense that have an internally paradoxical
structure and we have to deal with
that entire set of paradoxes or,
or we don't survive.
It's really a matter of survival.
Okay.
So,
so I'm,
and then you know,
there's this overarching symbol,
which is the dragon of chaos,
which is potential itself.
And it's the potential from which
all of these categories emerge.
And so the,
the,
the most abstract category
of our imagination is that,
which is beyond our understanding the
category of that which is beyond our
understanding.
And that seems to me to be represented
because we can only use the
representational
structures that we evolved,
is that it's represented in
our paradoxical representation
of the Predator and
the treasure that lies
beyond the perimeter,
that perimeter perimeters
of our safe societies.
So what's out there beyond,
well,
we don't know,
but we need to know because we need
always to deal with what we don't know.
So weirdly enough,
we have to come up with a category of
what we don't know in order to start
formalizing a theory about how we might
progress towards it and interact with
it.
It's very paradoxical idea and
there's a paradoxical answer,
right?
It's,
it's the terrible Predator that lurks in
the unknown that also harbors something
of great value.
Perfect.
That's exactly right.
And I think that that is a reflection of
the fact that human beings are Predator
animals and prey animals at the same time.
So what's out there in the,
in the terrible darkness,
something that can destroy you but also
something that you absolutely need.
So how do you,
how do you prepare yourself for that?
And that's the ultimate question of life.
It's not how do you deal with death,
although death is a sub component
of the terrible unknown,
I would say it's how do you deal with
that which is beyond your understanding,
which is constantly manifesting
itself in the world.
And that,
and that manifests itself every time
you categorize something and the thing
escapes from the category.
And that happens most interpersonal
relationships because people are so damn
complicated,
you get them figured out and box in.
You even make a contract
that neither review,
we'll jump outside the box,
but you jump outside the box continually.
And that's why a relationship
requires constant negotiation and
reconceptualization because you do not
exhaust the person with your perceptual
categories.
And of course you don't exhaust the world
with your perceptual categories ever.
This is partly why the existentialists,
they have this concept called alienation.
And the idea was that human beings
become alienated from their creative
products.
So,
and that is,
and here's why it happens.
So imagine a Henry Ford
makes the assembly line,
right?
So four,
it has no idea what's going to happen
when he makes the assembly line.
Like,
cause he's just trying to figure out a
fast way to make cars or he thinks that
what he's making his cars.
So he thinks he's making an assembly
line for cars and he thinks he's making
cars.
And you think,
well what's wrong with that?
Well first of all,
the assembly line absolutely
transformed the entire planet,
right?
Because it,
it brought in the era of
mass cheap manufacturing.
It's like it just,
it was way more than he thought it was.
And then did he make a car?
Well,
a car is something that hypothetically
takes you relatively effectively from
point a to point B.
It was really a replacement
for the horse and buggy.
I mean they,
the first cars looked like that
they were horseless carriages.
Well,
did he make a car while God,
it's God,
it's hard to tell what Henry Ford made.
He made a very effective way
for transforming the atmosphere.
Right.
And the fact that it also happened to
take you from point a to point B might be
just completely irrelevant compared
to the fact that it was the internal
combustion engine and its
rapid distribution completely
changed the constituent,
the,
you know,
the fundamental chemical structure
of the atmosphere itself.
It completely transformed cities.
It blew out the rural community.
Everyone moved to the cities,
right?
It made all the cities
built around the automobile.
But then it had this tremendous
political and economic significance too.
So I mean,
part of the reason that because you
think well is a car is a way to get from
point a to point B.
But no,
no,
it's not a machine.
It's also the abolishment of an idea.
And it's a very strange idea.
A collectivist society would have never
invented the car because the car is
predicated on the idea that you could
own a conveyance that would get only you
and only you from somewhere to somewhere
else without ever asking anybody for
any permission.
And so the funny thing is is when
you build something like that,
those presuppositions are built into it.
And then when you export
that say to Soviet Russia,
you don't get to,
they can't just take the car and leave
the political implications behind the
car.
The mere fact that you step into one and
drive it is an indication that you're
accepting the political,
ideological presuppositions that are
part of the fact that thing even exists.
And so well that's alienation.
It's like even something you make,
you think,
well you have control over what
you make because you've made it,
you understand.
It's like no you don't.
You understand a tiny fraction of it.
You launch it out in the world,
man,
and the snakes inside of it,
the hydrogen high inside of it
multiplied their heads massively,
constantly and you and you and
you can't really keep track of it.
And so,
so even even in your relationship
with created entities,
you still see the reemergence of this
underlying fundamental substructure,
right?
Even inside,
it's the,
it's the garden of Eden.
There's always a snake inside.
The thing that's walled in always,
always,
always.
Even God himself cannot get rid
of the snakes in the garden.
And partly what that means is that,
you know,
the garden is a conceptual system.
It's the conceptual system
within which people exist.
That's Eden is a,
is a walled garden.
Paradise means walled garden,
and it's walled because a walled
garden is where people live.
Because the wall is culture
and the garden is natured.
We always live in a structure that's
an amalgam of nature and culture.
So we set it up so it's paradise
as long as we're unconscious,
but we can't manage it because there's
always something chaotic that's coming in
that we will interact with.
That's human beings.
You put a snake in the garden.
It's the first bloody thing
we're going to talk to.
And for better or worse,
it makes us conscious and awake.
It makes us aware of our mortality.
It does all sorts of
terrible things to us,
but that doesn't matter because that's,
that's the path that human beings have.
What chosen,
because that's the
implication in that story.
And,
and it's,
it's very difficult.
It's a very difficult thing to answer
because we certainly choose each other for
self awareness and
consciousness and intelligence.
And I don't,
you know,
if you're,
if you're choosing a mate,
there's an arms race in human beings.
We're choosing intelligent
mates especially that's
especially the case for women
in relationship to men.
So,
um,
so that,
the idea that that's a choice,
well that's partly why it's eve that
makes that himself conscious in the garden
of Eden,
right?
She offers him the apple.
She's the one that makes
him self conscious.
And I think that's actually accurate
because the evidence from the evolutionary
biologist is that human sexuals female
sexual selection was one of the driving
factors that differentiated
us from chimpanzees.
It's a major factor.
Chimpanzee females are
not selective maters.
They go into estrus,
they'll mate with anything.
What happens is the dominant males chase
the subordinate males away and so they
end up leaving more offspring.
But it's not a consequence of selection
on the part of the females in human
beings.
It's completely different.
Concealed ovulation and intense
selection pressure from women on men.
You have twice as many female
ancestors as you have male ancestors,
and people can never have have
a hard time working that out.
Arithmetically but it's
not that problematic.
You just think on average,
every woman had one child,
half of men had none,
and the other half had to,
and that's approximately correct.
You average across the entire
history of human sexuality.
So human males in particular are
subject to a vicious selection,
pressure on the part of females.
And I also think that's partly why nature
is represented symbolically as female
among human beings.
Because after all,
nature is what selects.
There's no better definition of
nature then that which selects.